fame versus actual talent tila tequila
comes to money well what do you think of
people that have active social-media
followings but then there's no substance
behind what they're selling first off
you just described like three-quarters
of pop culture no substance not a bag
I'm Jersey Shore they're just one of
many shows or the Kardashians whatever I
mean the Cardassians have they have some
products that they sell but if you
really look at the foundation of most of
pop culture there is a lot more show
than go but they fit you know Adam and
people like this kind of mindless escape
entertainment so if somebody has and
when you refer to somebody having a huge
social following your furring to just
the person who friends everybody at
Facebook are you talking about somebody
who's actually made to say reality
television I think more Twitter Facebook
that have sort of an active social media
follow me not sense that it's self
generated it's not where a large how
that is pick them up what's the purpose
you know what if they don't have a
purpose it won't last in social media is
just like reality TV just like boy bands
these are all trans me you know they
evolve and change and and so I mean at
the end of the day you have to have
something to have staying power we look
at talent that lasts over the long haul
there is something substantive to the
product but if you're just going to be
if you're just looking to be famous well
then be famous but make sure you save
the money because it won't last your
fame is fleeting let's move the cliche
but you have to have something of
substance whether or not singing ability
acting ability writing ability at the
end of the day those who are best those
who have talent will succeed they'll do
well because they have the skill set to
endure
pain Facebook get it a call tomorrow
you